[Music]
my name is cheyenne cramer
and i am in the raleigh north carolina
area
and all of a sudden over the last 10
years i found myself just kind of
creeping up the scale a little at a time
and
ended up getting on the scales last
december and going oh my god i haven't
weighed this much since i was pregnant
and that was kind of the key for me
where i said i have to do something
fred van lu is my sponsor he had stuck
me
in the group for the rev 90 challenge
probably a year ago
and i wasn't ready for it then and but
i've been watching and i'd been
following and i'd been listening and
seeing what people were doing
and i just said you know i i got to make
the jump
i followed everything in the meal
planner just as closely as i possibly
could because i said you know i'm going
to give this 100
i really want to see this work and um
you know it just it got more and more
exciting every day as i kept seeing the
scales go down
i started at about 181 and
recently saw about 136 so
it's it's right in the area of a 45
pound weight loss at this point in time
i would tell people not to give up on
themselves and just
you know keep watching keep being aware
and if all of a sudden you start to
feel that that shift like you know it's
my time then i said go for it